Speaker 1: The other thing that I have to
tell you, I enjoyed watching this weekend
and usually I don't enjoy this.
Donald Trump glitched very badly, causing
psychiatric nurses to email me and to say,
David, I'm recognizing what's going on with
Trump.
So this is this this is this is pretty serious.
Donald Trump was scheduled to have a rally
in Nebraska on Friday evening.
There were big storms.
And so the rally was postponed until yesterday,
Sunday.
And Donald Trump truly seemed to have completely
lost his wits.
He didn't seem to know what was going on.
This was a nearly two hour long.
It was like a sprawling, almost Fidel Castro,
like droning on about nothing, nearly 2 hours
of this stuff.
The crowd was as bored as ever, and Trump
continued to have these brain glitches making
no sense.
Just like Swiss cheese, you know, mayonnaise
is up there in his skull.
My absolute favorite moment.
And I tweeted about this right away and it
started trending on Twitter.
And then the clip ultimately getting millions
of views.
Trump didn't know who he who he had endorsed.
Trump claimed that he endorsed a nonexistent
candidate by blending the names of two different
candidates and looking off to the side saying,
Who did we endorse?
This is an incredible moment.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 4: That's what they're waiting for.
They're waiting for one race.
You know, we've endorsed Dr. Oz, we've endorsed
JP Greg, JD Mendell, and he's doing great.
Speaker 1: So let let me back that up.
First, he says we've endorsed JP.
Right.
And he looks over to the side of JP, I don't
know who's JP.
He says, we've endorsed JD Mendell.
Now, this is a blend of two people who are
running against each other in the Ohio Republican
Senate primary.
J.D.
Vance is one candidate and Josh Mandel is
another candidate.
Now, it's not just that Trump doesn't know
who the hell he endorsed, and he makes up
a name of a person that doesn't exist.
Mandel spent the entire election cycle trying
to get Trump's endorsement.
He didn't get it.
Trump goes to JD Vance.
JD Vance basically threw himself at the altar
of Trump and said anything he could.
Apologized for the criticisms of Trump from
years ago in order to finally get Trump's
endorsement.
And then Trump ends up mentioning his opponent.
Trump ends up mentioning the guy he's running
against by saying JD Mandel two days before
the primary, he confuses who he even endorsed.
If Biden did this, they'd be saying, Oh, we
got to remove him for the 25th Amendment.
He's demented.
He's got dementia.
He can't think.
After seeing this, I got an email from a nurse
educator who also worked as an aged care registered
nurse and said, This is a quote from from
her, I cared for people with dementia for
many years and know a lot about it.
Trump demonstrates a telling symptom of dementia
called perseverance.
He says the same phrases over and over again.
Everyone knows it's more than has ever happened
before, and it's really a shame.
He uses the same gestures over and over again,
pointing upward, making the circle with the
thumb and forefinger.
He tells the same stories over and over again.
He seems unable to grasp and repeat new stories
in this case.
This is new stuff, right?
JD Mandell, this is these are new candidates.
There's no what's going on.
He uses simple language with restricted vocabulary.
He pads his language with unnecessary phrases.
He can't speak specifically, only in generalities.
No one can diagnose dementia with certainty
in this way, but it doesn't look good.
By the way, this JD Mandel gaffe hasn't appeared
on Truth Social.
It hasn't appeared on Getter.
The users on Parler aren't talking about it.
Fox News isn't talking about it.
They'll never even know that it happened.
It actually, it's almost like that time when
Trump got Obama's name wrong.
Obama Now you guys remember that.
Okay, so then just glitch after glitch after
glitch, there was no actual substance to the
rally, so I won't even bore you with it.
But then at another point, Trump glitched
on Mitt Romney's name and you can see that
he kind of has this twitch when he.
Speaker 4: Does it, even though it was totally
made up.
That was about a guy named a rhino named Mitt
Romney or Mitt Romney.
Speaker 1: Or it's almost quite literally
like someone stopping a record.
Mitt Romney, Mitt Romney or Mitt Romney.
Listen to it once.
Speaker 4: More, even though it's totally
made up.
That was about a guy named a rhino named Mitt
Romney.
Rick.
Mitt Romney.
Speaker 1: That error is really quite a noise.
And then lastly, trying to talk about Billy
the Kid, I guess talking about Billy the kid's
bovine counterpart, Billy the CUD.
This one is wacky.
Speaker 4: I've had more investigations.
And Jesse James, Billy, they could.
Speaker 1: You really don't know whether to
laugh or cry, but this is a guy who seems
very unwell and it's a combination of weaponised
narcissism.
It's I don't know what else.
You know, Fidel Castro was known Castro was
known for four or five hour speeches.
Trump 2 hours of Trump is as bad as five of
Castro, I would argue, just endlessly going
over a lot of the same stuff.
Crowd Visibly bored.
And then the glitches.
The glitches are just coming so frequently.
So what's going on with them?
I don't know.
But even Trump now is saying, you know, it's
possible that health might be a reason I don't
run in 2024.
Who knows?
We're going to keep following it.
And again, for all the people saying Biden
doesn't look good.
If you look at Biden at the White House Correspondents
Dinner this weekend and you look at Trump
talking about JD Mandel, a quite literally
imaginary person, seems pretty clear to me
which one's worse off.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this